[Music]
the major showdown on TV last night the
new American Idol went head-to-head
against the boys for the first time and
the results are in so who came out on
top here we go let me just say to my
judges just wait
the wait is over last night both shows
brought the women of pop to tears on NBC
33 year old Stephanie skipper saying
Kelly's ballad piece by piece
causing Kelly to choke up the fact that
you picked that song on Idol the back
story of 25 year old David Francisco was
the trigger for Katy
I actually got hit by a car and
paralyzed from the waist down let's see
[Music]
I've lost my voice but like it's not
like we're we're having just these crazy
obscure people come in that that we just
say no right off the bat Amin week so
when there is an outrageous audition at
least the contestant can sing the wild
moments on the voice are mostly thanks
to Kelly last night when 20 year old
Hannah Goble sang Alicia's classic if I
ain't got you
all four coaches wanted her Kelly locked
Alisha then Kelly made this passionate
pitch if I live in Nashville
I live in Nashville as I say those kinds
of moments seem to be resonating with
America so far the voice came out on top
averaging 11.7 million viewers
compared to idols eight point four
million
[Music]